l'objectif vous le connaissez 50
millions de français primo vacciner
c'est à dire ayant reçu au moins une
injection dans les prochains jours nous
avons franchi ce soir la barre des 48
millions et au rythme actuel nous serons
aux 50 millions au courant de la
première semaine de septembre c'est déjà
un résultat qui dépasse non seulement
toutes les enquêtes d'opinion sur les
intentions de vaccination des français
mais qui dépasse de 10 millions
l'objectif initial que nous nous étions
fixés mi juin lorsque nous avions
franchi l'objectif des 30 millions des
prix novak signer et ce grâce à
l'intervention du président de la
république le 12 juillet dernier qui a
clairement booster la vaccination dans
notre pays le mot est faible et qui a
fait re décoller notre campagne
vaccinale au coeur de l'été nous sommes
désormais au dessus des taux de
vaccination de la plupart des pays et
même de l'angleterre longtemps cité en
exemple
après avoir dépassé l'allemagne fin
juillet puis l'italie début août c'est
un bon résultat que nous devons à la
mobilisation historique je pèse le mot
de nos soignants pompiers agents des
collectivités locales bénévoles
associations et bien sûr des agences
régionales de santé et des préfets que
je voudrais tous ici remercier
sincèrement les 50 millions nous les
attendrons donc mais nous souhaitons
aller au delà au delà parce qu'il y à
plus de 57 millions de français âgés de
12 ans et plus qui sont appelées à se
faire vacciner et si le vaccin n'est pas
obligatoire il est indispensable si l'on
regarde par tranche d'âge vous voyez que
toutes les catégories d'âge sont bien
couvertes y compris d'ailleurs les plus
jeunes bien que la vaccination leur est
été ouverte plus récemment à la mi juin
la vaccination des 40% d'adolescents
restants elle sera facilitée par le
protocole vaccination mis en place via
les collèges les lycées les universités
qui s'il restera bien sûr facultatif
reste très fortement conseillé la
priorité des priorités ce sont les deux
millions de français âgés ou malades qui
n'ont pas encore été vaccinés nous
faisons absolument tout pour les
accompagner des barnums de vaccins dans
les villes et dans les villages la
vaccination des aînés à domicile le
transport sanitaire gratuits vers les
centres on appelle les non vaccinés et
on passe aussi par les médecins
traitants il ya plus de 280 opération
éphémère menées dans des centres
commerciaux l'assurance maladie aussi
appel au total ce sont plus d'un million
de français fragiles qui ont d'ores et
déjà été vaccinées grâce à ce qu'on
appelle le aller vers